Merry Christmas everybody I'm Walter
Benes yank I'm Heather Ruth and I'm I an
away and this is top five as a special
Christmas gift for you guys today we've
got another more phenomenal Power
Rangers countdown again hello have you
done Tim Curry yet well he's not really
my type four top five have you covered
tomb curries performances on top five no
he's your most requested subject why not
the guy's got a ton of credits that's a
lot of movies to watch in a very short
amount of time critic do it or you're
fired
what diner you're fired we haven't done
the research look up why look up top
five craziest Tim Curry performances by
the Nostalgia Critic if this feels a
little dishonest
you wanted it you got it these are the
top five craziest Tim Curry performances
number five herkermer Homolka in congo
of course Tim Curry's in a movie about
killer gorillas and of course he's the
best part dr. Peter Elliott has taught a
gorilla named Amy to speak through sign
language amy has been recently
indicating that she wants to be returned
home to Africa dr. Elliot's goals
aligned with a mogul named RV Travis who
sends his former daughter-in-law to the
same region in hopes of retrieving his
sons diamond hunting team that just went
missing along with other eccentric types
such as a Romanian treasure hunter and
an American tour guide the group runs
into big problems in the jungle that
prove a myth true I know what you're
thinking
I did the gorilla suit thing way better
Curry's character in this movie is
pretty Shady
big shock right you're not sure where he
stands until later in the film since
he's hiding his true motive most of the
time we get to see this classic Tim
Curry performance that's constantly
bubbling beneath the surface you've been
taking your medication and I will have
mine the Lions he has to deliver in this
movie would be ridiculous for any other
actor to read but since he is who he is
curry makes every word memorable the way
only he can we must follow the gorilla
where she leads the fact that he's
playing a Romanian just adds to the
absurdity that accent is so much fun
I will pay I will pay for Amy to go home
push me at least
Potter place as peculiar as this role
was it's only the beginning number for
premier anatoliy rudenko in command &
Conquer red alert 3 we get all types of
curry in these cutscenes mild curry
medium curry spicy curry and extra hot
curry oh come on you know I had to in
command & Conquer Red Alert threes
alternate universe there are three
factions of power vying for world
domination tim curry plays a soviet
commanding officer who gives you orders
throughout the gameplay not only does he
boss you around but also every other
character he comes in contact with
curries natural demeanor is perfect for
a character in charge who could stab you
in the back at any moment if you cross
him or outlived your usefulness Korea's
dialect is truly something to behold and
we get a few classic curry snarls
peppered in as well there are a few more
recognizable actors throughout the game
but I really have to commend curry for
committing to some incredibly silly
dialogue like this amazing gem I'm
escaping to the one place that hasn't
been corrupted by capitalism space
ultimately no matter what type of curry
you prefer this performance has range
you already made the curry joke yeah but
I was dishing out seconds please stop
alright moving on number three Long John
Silver in Muppet Treasure Island
I can never see anyone else in this role
he nailed it nugget Treasure Island
mostly follows the classic tale while
disguised as a ship's cook Long John
Silver befriends Jim Hawkins an orphan
boy with a secret treasure map once
revealed as a pirate Long John Silver
manipulates Jim into giving him the map
but he may have been harboring a soft
spot for Jim after all
[Music]
for an integral role Tim curry did not
disappoint
yet again Curry's charisma lures you
into his performance his personality
makes me want to trust him despite all
of his actions
leaving me as conflicted as Jim in one
scene he'll be docile and subservient
and in another he's conniving and
venomous other times he's all at once
Korea's ability to sincerely flip
emotions on a dime is captivating and
adds dimension to a children's movie
that a lesser actor might have skimped
on it's also worth noting that actors
playing opposite of puppets really have
to pull their own weight because
sweetums is not exactly emotive from
singing shanties to petting Polly's
Curry's performance is a wild ride that
will not soon be forgotten
number two dr. Franken further a
scientist in the Rocky Horror Picture
Show it's just a jump to the left you
bring your knees in in 1975 the world
was introduced to dr. Frank inverter a
scientist and was never quite the same
again Rocky Horror Picture Show first
opened in London it was generally panned
and actually pulled from the limited
theaters it was released in due to poor
numbers little did people know at the
time the cultural phenomenon it would
become the movie quickly caught on as a
midnight showing with audience
participation it is now a cult classic
and the longest-running theatrical
release all over the world people still
attend and participate in these midnight
shows it's quite an experience if you've
never been part of what draws people
into Rocky Horror Picture Show is the
inimitable charismatic and over-the-top
performance by Tim Curry he brings life
to every scene that he's in curry plays
the sky
from transsexual transyl
[Music]
who is an alien mad scientist that is
working on creating a perfect superhuman
man
he helps distraught travelers Brad and
Janet come to a sexual awakening it's
just as amazingly insane as it sounds
curry steals the show with his full
commitment to the role he uses
over-the-top facial expressions and
dramatic movements his confidence and
swagger command the screen he's
seductive and wild the audience is drawn
into every song he performs to the
fullest it's not hard to see why this
performance has become iconic and keep
audiences shivering in anticipation
[Music]
and the number one craziest Tim Curry
performance in Pennywise the dancing
clown in it in this Stephen King
miniseries from 1997 young outcasts in
Derry Maine band together when a
supernatural killer clown named penny
wise goes on a child murdering rampage
thirty years later they're all called
back to the scene of the crime where
penny wise is making a terrifying
comeback as you can tell the critic has
bent our rules a bit here usually we
only include theatrically released
movies in our active performance list
but this is a special case Mr curry
cannot be bound by conventional
limitations it is the perfect example of
that I'll admit I never saw the original
90s version before watching it for this
video but I still remember hearing about
it as a kid my classmates would talk
about it as the scariest movie out there
back then that was not something I was
interested in seeing horror was not my
thing
even now I'm not a huge fan of the genre
in general but I've warmed up to the
classics as has been pointed out before
on this channel curry is living it up as
penny wise in this miniseries I'm sure
it would have freaked me the heck out as
a kid but as an adult his over-the-top
portrayal is pretty funny to watch
pilly all take your pick
berry boy kiss me that boy and we all
know everyone's favorite part while most
of Curry's performance comes off as
humorous there are still a few legit
creepy scenes like when Bev tries to
return to her child at home but instead
of finding her father still living there
it's this nice old lady that is able to
scope out her old home but soon she
realizes the nice old lady is anything
but she runs out of the house and looks
back to see that it's been condemned and
boarded up the whole time on the porch
stands Pennywise mocking her I thought
that was a legitimately great sequence
capped by curry
Beth seemed so scared it looked like she
was thinking
sorry I had to get a Smallville joke in
there you remember who she played on
that show right Tim Curry is one of a
kind and has had a most unique career
for himself I hope you've enjoyed our
look back at some of the craziest roles
in his legendary filmography we want to
hear what you guys think what's your
favorite Tim Curry performance what do
you want to see us cover next on the
show leave a comment and let us know to
keep in touch you could like my Facebook
page or follow along on Twitter so you
can find me on Facebook Twitter
Instagram or subscribe to my animated
movie review series right here on
YouTube and you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday nights top 5 we'll be taking a
few weeks off but we'll see you next
year in 2019 with brand-new episodes so
Merry Christmas Happy Holidays Happy New
Year
[Music]
[Applause]
no hang on I have call waiting
hello no no you got the wrong finger
I might be insane
you